[Music]
in all in news all of Rowan submitted by
come visit Kerala India Kerala Kerala
Kerala a wife divorced her gambling
addicted husband after he made the worst
possible bet they may be lost their home
oh she waited though - like he's gonna
win it I'm gonna say if he but if he
loses it all he say it's difficult being
with an addict have an open journal for
those white girls out there named Jess
you know it's hard for a woman to stick
by her man who enjoys the lust of
gambling oh well he didn't bet their
home do you want to take him kids but he
bets three children both are right Oh
what kids end
oh [ __ ] when you bet your family all he
sees [ __ ] that means he was pretty
confident really confident about her you
guys are looking the wrong side of it
really calm you probably got a really
good head it was just in the three that
he won no Eli I mean it's the same thing
one like you tell someone something and
then they go what I put on my mom that
this happened you know see the other
person is really stupid when we say we
put it on our mom everyone knows that
you're not really putting it on anything
you're just trying to show them like I'm
Howie serious but that's what he
probably meant to though he goes dude I
put my kids in my mom no but the
difference was like that on my kids on
my mother
no but the person who submitted the
article oh is it oh well you that outfit
does take place in India
[Applause]
they try to collect payment they did see
they tried to collect payment meaning
like you know taking a wife and kids
what would why would you pop them right
if I was a gambler I'll be like [ __ ] bad
I don't want your problems their
responsibilities right it's like damn
what am I gonna do with them black
market pearl clean for them see they
wanted someone to cook and clean for
them and you should use one better by
maids what the father you is just being
sarcastic and it took a little too
seriously
I bet you yeah what what do you have to
offer you could take going on [ __ ]
goat racing and drag racing there's a
god like getting ready yeah so when the
dude went to their home to collect the
Wow hilarious
the wife certified don't you understand
sarcasm
so I started processing screaming and
it's a five-course [ __ ] tell her I
just have someone show up for your door
you're mine yeah he just like let them
in the house and [ __ ] like it's going on
right now just open the door and he just
put her on the shoulder shoulder
shoulder the man started forcing the
wife to go with him so at that point
that's when a village council was called
Oh oh my god the village came together
all the wise men of the village so what
you're telling me is that you bet your
wife died for her to go I don't know
yeah exactly you to go that's how you
think about village council concluded no
they're like just dumb you're not then
you can't trade your wife did you at
hope right yeah they ended up deciding
that out of it so the wife and one kid
gets a stake the other kid has no war no
vecas and the chills I don't like that
so I guess slavery is legal in India oh
that's great dude
so that kid automatically knows which
one is the most hated child for sure
there's no other way around ticket I
mean are they like gonna be farmhands or
something I hope so I was gonna say the
worst thing that would be like I would
think is that they're gonna be serving
yeah there were little kids to ever
hooked up kind of little I don't know
their exact age but they got married in
2012 and so she said after this whole
thing she filed for divorce and she also
filed a police complaint against the
husband and five other men
five men took her child i I guess like
maybe that was the council the village
council members that's good that's so
awkward in that household then no they
divorced okay I thought that she was
still with him that's just so weird she
ended up marrying somebody else the kids
no more than six years old then the
oldest yeah no more than that oh my god
and what was this like argument to his
wife like did you really like them that
much anyway you can't recover from that
when someone takes your try like I can't
imagine you know any mean being like I
gave away our baby and then no there's
no work I would why would you want
another person's kid I know that's a
dumbest thing I've ever heard in my life
[ __ ] that I mean maybe cuz you're normal
it doesn't make sense but for [ __ ]
pervy weirdos well I mean I wouldn't
even if it wasn't to [ __ ] the kid right
like they did this very often back in a
day where it's like people are farmhand
yeah yeah we're like product or like
servants or whatever so I'm like what
what can they do today is just maybe
[ __ ] village chief like he had to deal
with this stupid ass [ __ ] you know what
I mean well this might be a serious deal
like this might be like the [ __ ] that
they to hit on a lawyer yes okay you owe
two gods in an elephant Anna
it's just like a regular Monday for them
ya know the older kids like what kind of
chores could they do here I'm saying if
you're gonna take the baby that just
that just leaves me a bit more I got a
few ideas six years old five years old
we don't know I think I'd buy them a
really cute little suit like a tuxedo
and have them be my Butler and I'll have
them what have those one little guys oh
yeah with that go like yeah and then
I'll teach them how to tell time and
I'll give them a pocket watch so every
time be like what's my clothes and then
they could pull it out yeah white gloves
yep and then maybe I'll teach them a
little bit of magic so then they can do
magic shows during dinner and stuff yeah
they'll be really cute I don't want that
kid going to your house I know somebody
can perform tricks for your dinner party
weight in vice versa can the wife gamble
the husband away that should be hella
funny there she goes where joke's on you
do you have to go down centrally tries
to lose but she keeps winning like [ __ ]
I got the twelve children now great good
when I hear stories like this I'm like
oh thank god I was born here yeah not
this right they would still get the kid
but they'll just beat the [ __ ] out of
chop that's all that's all said I think
you would have to gamble yourself away
you have to chop off your fingers or
some [ __ ] wearing Japan oh yeah if you
can't pay your debt they'll just chop
your head off mm-hmm really yeah not
anymore
yeah they'll just kill you now but yeah
I mean you it's still not like America
though there's no personal freedom
you know there's we have a lot of
independent and personal freedom in this
country as much as that will [ __ ]
complain it's like they have the room to
complain and they've never been to
another country it's kind of a live
there or whatever so they're just
blinded to their [ __ ] privileges so
when they complain about all this [ __ ]
they have no [ __ ] clue what it's like
yeah wait what do you know the the
gambling game that he was playing I
don't like rock paper scisors I'm
telling you it's go drag racing dude
I don't order try to [ __ ] it it's it's
like which coconut would drop first just
[ __ ] waiting there all day the pop of
the tree oh no it's just the wind
hilarious I would I have to know the
game I want to know what he was so
confident that he would bet what kind of
snacks they have the concession stands
like curry popcorn I want to go to
Indian Stadium that's time you just made
that up we don't even know if that
exists it's crazy yeah it's like the
NASCAR of Indian yeah you have like
mango lassi Slurpees instead of hotdogs
it's hot gods get your hot goats police
are now investigating and they set up a
team to trace the man who took her kid
because for the past two years I've been
in 2015 for the past two years she
doesn't know where her kid is they have
different laws depending on like what
part of India you are maybe it's like a
really rural area and so like in their
mind they're like it is done now all
right in the actual city they're like
[Laughter]
yeah we are what are you talking about
he bet that they lost it's kosher
I don't know any Indian people that yeah
it's like where the [ __ ] does this even
come from yeah that's crazy how separate
the backwoods of India is compared to
the city I want to visit and everyone
tells me you don't but I don't wanna do
well I have Indian people that tell me
not to go so I have it's gonna all my
friends that wet said it's [ __ ]
horrible yeah they they came back and
they're like you don't want to go and
they're probably going to the touristy
places which is amazing to be palatable
and it's still horrible they don't like
Mumbai and they're like going to what's
the other one room ah there's like
that's not gonna go to you like there's
nothing but trash and
like orphaned children [ __ ]
surrounding your car and begging the
whole way dude it's like from the
airport to your hotel you're just like
[ __ ] sad like oh my god starting at
the airport like like driving to cuz
usually the airport is like I'm gonna at
the airport but like out of the airport
through your shuttle right and he's like
everything is spicy even when you ask
them for no spice they're like I got you
bro but he's like I think the cook is
like nah I can't I got to do a little
bit of spicy and they don't have a God
yeah cuz the only people I know that
really enjoy going to India are white
people hipster I keep on they love it
they're like it was authentic as hell
but I'm like what does that mean dude
like you got diarrhea and you like from
drinking the [ __ ] muddy water yeah
you could say it wasn't that great
nobody nobody gonna be [ __ ] oh you
know what it was Oprah
[Music]
[Music]